democrats obsess over january 6th in
order to promote changing all the rules
joe biden doesn't know whether to lock
down harder or leave people alone and
patent oswald throws dave chappelle
under the bus i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let me remind you that
you're spending way too much on your
cell phone bill did you know that you
don't just vote in november you vote
every single month with the money that
you spend and the companies you spend it
with if you're still a customer of
verizon or at t or t-mobile you're
choosing to support the candidates and
issues that they donate to okay that
means like biden pelosi schumer etc well
you could just spend less money and also
not support those people via pure talk
pure talks i've said uses the exact same
tower same 5g networks as one of those
big companies but with the peace of mind
that you are supporting a veteran-run
business of business whose employees are
right here in the united states so yes
this is one monthly bill you can be
proud to pay oh and by the way it'll
probably be about half of what your
current cell phone bill is because the
average family is saving over 800
dollars a year so head on over to
puretalk.com find the plan that is right
for you find the phone that's right for
you or just bring your own and then
because they love my listeners enter
promo code ben shapiro you will save 50
off your very first month of pure talk
usa coverage that is puretalk.com promo
code ben shapiro for 50 off your first
month you could be saving hundreds of
bucks down the road and not supporting
the people that you don't particularly
like with your dollars alrighty so the
democrats the media they are all revved
up this week in preparation for thursday
because thursday of course is the one
year anniversary of the biggest event
the sing the signal event in american
history january 6. the worst thing that
has ever happened in the history of the
planet now listen you don't have to
downplay the evils of january 6th in
order to recognize that what january 6th
was was a really bad aberration i mean
the imagery of january 6th was quite
terrible you had americans who were
storming the capitol building you had
people beating up police officers with
poles he had a woman who was shot to
death while trying to break through a
window to get to congress people had
people in the halls of the capitol
paying for mike pence and none of that
is good all of that is really bad and a
lot of those folks were acting because
they were emotionally revved up by
president trump's prevarications over
the prior two months about how the
election was stolen it was all election
fraud how he was the rightful president
how mike pence could somehow illegally
shift the votes in the election or not
count votes in the election and throw
the entire process into chaos and then
continue trump in the presidency none of
that was true
so you don't have to downplay the evils
of january 6th in order to recognize
that the left is now doing with january
6th is absurd and left has declared that
january 6th is the be all end all it is
the only thing that matters in human
history and it only matters because if
there's an emergency if there's an
ongoing emergency this means that they
can take emergency power in the same way
that the left used covid in order to
grab control and never relinquish it of
every aspect of american life in major
american cities like new york or los
angeles or chicago in exactly the same
way the left is now suggesting that
january 6 is not a bad thing that
happened a horrible thing that that was
perpetrated by people who are now in
jail
and and that was revved up by a
president who's no longer president no
instead they have to say january 6th is
every day that was literally the name of
an editorial from the new york times
yesterday january 6th is every day every
day is january 6. well no it's not but
the reason they have to say that is
because if there's an ongoing threats
democracy each and every day if that
threat is ongoing continuous never
ending that means the only way to fight
back against that is to seize control of
all the levers of power
just as they did with covet if there's
an ongoing emergency we must have
emergency power if there's an ongoing
electoral emergency we must have
emergency electoral power now here is
the thing
january 6th
the the riot at the capitol building
that was really not even quite
unprecedented i know that we've all sort
of memory hold what happened in 2017 but
over 200 people were arrested in
washington dc when trump was inaugurated
in 2017. i mean there were burning cop
cars 3 000 members of local state
federal law enforcement backed by 5 000
national guard members and police
officers from as far away as new jersey
patrolled the streets
and this according to the nbc news
report from the time
acting police chief peter newsham said
that by around 6 30 pm eastern time
things had calmed down but authorities
were still monitoring several groups at
the same time police were preparing for
the women's march on washington it was
expected to draw 200 hundred thousand
protesters and people started calling
themselves the resistance
in uh in an ode to the french resistance
during the nazi occupation literally
right away
and you know what democracy didn't end
democracy continued
some of these criminals went to jail
many of these criminals did not
but 200 people were in fact arrested on
inauguration day 2017. nobody remembers
that because he got memory hold in the
same way that the congressional baseball
attack got memory hold because the
perpetrator of that attack was a was a
hardcore democrat who supported bernie
sanders in the same way that we've now
memory hold the murder of a bunch of
white people by a black driver in
waukesha wisconsin in the same way that
we've memory hold a black lives matter
supporter murdering six police officers
in dallas in 2016. any time there's a
perpetrator who's of the left it gets
memory hold any time there's a
perpetrator who is purportedly of the
right then it becomes a signal moment in
american history and january 6th is just
the latest evidence of this why because
well the left can't use any of the other
moments that i talked about
the left can't use the fact that there
were 200 people who were arrested in
2017 and the windows were being spent
the left can't use the fact there was
five billion dollars in uninsured
property damage probably that was done
during summer 2020 over the george floyd
protest riots
they can't use any of that but they can
use january 6th they can pretend that
january 6th is some sort of turning
point in american history that it is a
constant ever-present threat that the
laws that have been attempted to to be
passed in various states around the
country are a true threat to democracy
so what they will typically do when they
have this discussion is they will bring
up bills that didn't even pass they'll
bring up bills that for example allow
for election results to be thrown out
they never talk about the bills that do
pass like the bill in georgia that
passed and then was made the subject of
major league baseball pulling the
all-star game from georgia
you remember this that bill loosened
some of the voting restrictions on for
example early voting
that bill was not unprecedented in any
way but it was treated as unprecedented
because again the goal here is not to
prevent another january 6th the goal
here is to prevent another election the
goal here is to make it more difficult
to run a free fair and honest election
and it doesn't require you to sympathize
with the cause of the january 6th
rioters to say this all you have to have
our eyes
all you have to have our ears these
democrats are not hiding the ball here
they're making very clear that they seek
to exploit january 6th in order to press
forward their agenda as always agenda
uber ellis i will get some more on this
in just one second first
even though you are far from ordinary
the truth is that erectile dysfunction
is pretty common in fact 52 of guys aged
40 to 70 experience some form of ed over
the course of that time go to
getroman.com ben right now speak to a
u.s licensed healthcare professional
about ed get 15 bucks off your first
month of treatment a lot of a lot of
folks who have ed they tend to ignore it
they tend to think okay it'll go away
it'll go away well why would you suffer
through ed when you could just get it
solved quickly and discreetly and
inexpensively with roman with roman you
get a free online evaluation and ongoing
care for ed all from the comfort and
privacy of your home a u.s licensed
healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate it ships you
free with two-day shipping
the whole process is straightforward
convenient and discreet getting started
is simple just go to getroman.com ben
complete an online visit take care of
your ed without leaving your home
complete an online visit today connect
with a us licensed healthcare
professional and get it taken care of go
to getroman.com
bend today if you're prescribed get 15
bucks off your first month of ed
treatment make sure you're ready to have
confidence and control this season roman
ready head on over to getroman.com ben
today if you're prescribed get 15 bucks
off your first month of ed treatment
okay so
the democrats of course are are making
clear that they are tying january 6 to
2022 right the midterms the fact is the
democrats know they're going to get
skunked in the midterms unless they
change the rules and so the rules have
to be changed and the way that they seek
to change the rules is with a couple of
bills they originally had the for the
people act that completely fell apart
because it had no support then they
started trying to push forward the the
john lewis
voting rights advancement act that is
senate bill 4 hr bill 4
right so that that that particular act
is designed to
vastly expand federal oversight of state
and local elections via use of the
voting rights act the suggestion being
that
without any evidence of actual racist
intent
if there is quote unquote disparate
impact in redistricting for example the
federal government will now have to
oversee that
there's not a lot of republican support
for for the john lewis voting rights act
because there shouldn't be hans von
spakovsky rights for heritage foundation
has a very good breakdown of the john
lewis voting rights act and exactly what
it would do
he says the stated purpose is to prevent
racial discrimination but it would force
racial gerrymandering make race the
predominant factor in the election
process advance the partisan interests
of one political party and prevent
common sense election reforms like voter
id it would also change section 3 from
requiring a show of intentional
discrimination to allow other violations
of the vra to count toward triggering
pre-clearance coverage
in other words
normally it was under the voting rights
act which was passed in 1965 the idea
was that there were a bunch of southern
states that were going to gerrymander
black voters out of any ability to have
any impact on elections and so the
voting rights act said that particular
states have to go through a
pre-clearance process with the federal
government to demonstrate that they were
not in fact acting in racially
discriminatory ways then there was a
supreme court decision a couple of years
ago that it's now been 50 years since
the voting rights act and so we don't
need to do this anymore because there's
not evidence that there's a dramatic
attempt in southern states particularly
to quash the black vote
okay well that basically the the
act here would be an attempt to undo
that supreme court decision and again
make it the doj's prerogative to draw
districts so if you want merrick garland
drawing districts then this is the bill
for you
of course the doj has a history of
filing unwarranted objections under
section 5 based on its bias in favor of
liberal advocacy groups and that bias
has not changed of course
so that is one of the acts that the
democrats are seeking to move forward
there's another act that the democrats
are seeking to move forward as well
that does something similar
and that is an attempt to to put into
place all sorts of
ballot restrictions preventing voter id
from being implemented encouraging
ballot harvesting
all the rest of it
but they don't have support for it so
what they're trying to do is cudgel joe
manchin and kirsten cinema into killing
the filibuster in order so that the
support will then will then happen if
they kill the filibuster then presumably
they can get it done with 50 votes plus
kamala harris now here's the thing if
you're a mansion or cinema you really
have no incentive to kill the filibuster
the reason you have no incentive to kill
the filibuster is because then you're
actually going to be held to account see
the filibuster protects cinema and
mansion
the filibuster these are two
blue senators from red or purple states
right arizona is a purple state and
west virginia is a bright red state the
filibuster protects joe manchin and
kirsten cinema because they can vote in
favor of democratic proposals
on the actual floor
and then they can
not have that have any consequence
because the filibuster kills it and they
never have to vote for anything
controversial if they kill the
filibuster suddenly they're held to
account by their own democratic party
base and or republican voters who don't
like how they vote so there's no
interest for joe manchin or kirsten
cinema in killing the filibuster
so democrats have tried to create
selective kills of the filibuster what
they're trying to do is encourage
mansion and cinema to kill the
filibuster only on bills where mansion
and cinema really really like to build
a mansion in cinema it doesn't make a
lot of sense for them to do that because
once they've opened the door then the
question becomes why don't they just do
that for everything
according to politico today a group of
democrats including rafael warnock of
georgia tim kaine of virginia amy
klobuchar of minnesota and jeff merkley
of oregon began meeting with joe manchin
to design a modified version of hr1 that
all 50 democrats could back they came up
with this freedom to vote act it is a
massive reform bill addressing voting
rights election integrity campaign
finance and gerrymandering but it is
more tailored to address problems of
electoral subversion like removing
election officials without cause that
became apparent after 2020. mansion
shopped the bill to republicans nobody
joined up
so they were now talking about nuking
the filibuster that is very very
unlikely it is unlikely that they are
going to nuke the filibuster especially
because the republicans do have an
alternative
the republican alternative has been
pushed by folks like yuv olivine over at
american enterprise institute the
republican alternative is basically to
prevent some of the worst sort of
election bill abuses that could
theoretically be put forward like simply
throwing away votes
right in favor of a reform to the
electoral count act you remember
that the electoral count act was the
bill that was that was misinterpreted by
some legal advisers to
president trump in order to suggest that
mike pence could simply throw out
electoral votes and then change the
certification of the election that's
really not what the eca says we talked
about it at length back during december
and january the electoral contact of 18
1887 does not allow the vice president
of the united states to simply throw out
votes that have been state certified
yvolovin says it could be clarified
he says that some republicans insist the
process of counting and certifying the
votes in some states was corrupt in
2020. there's no evidence to support
specific claims on this front but
greater care and transparency about
post-election administration would serve
us well regardless and could render such
claims easier to test and refute in ways
that would build public
confidence reforms focused on these
themes would be a more productive path
than what we've seen so far which are
efforts focused mostly on voting itself
on who can cast a ballot when and by
what means
if we take both parties most high minds
and arguments at face value they're
worried about problems that barely exist
it's easier than ever to vote
registration has gotten much simpler so
democrats complaining that there is a an
attempt to crack down on voting they're
just lying it's not true voter turnout
is at historic highs black and white
voting rates now rise and fall together
meanwhile voter fraud is vanishingly
rare as well the most thorough database
of cases maintained by one of the
staunchest conservative defenders of
election integrity suggests a rate of
fraud so low it could not meaningfully
affect outcomes
so what exactly could be done
well theoretically they should turn to
narrowly tailored legislation says
uvolvin focused on post-election
administration
such a bill could for example limit the
ability of state officials to remove
local election administrators without
cause and prohibit the harassment of
election workers it could mandate a
mechanism for post-election audits while
requiring a clear standard for rendering
election results final
it could modernize and simplify the eca
some of those ideas were included in the
freedom to vote act which is the
democratic joe manchin joined bill
but that bill also includes a bunch of
other stuff like campaign finance
redistricting that make it unacceptable
so they could narrow it down so that
will probably be mitch mcconnell's
return offer to the democrats and
democrats will turn it down because they
don't care about that democrats aren't
interested in shoring up the electoral
account act democrats are interested in
completely revising the way we do voting
in this country why well because if they
don't then they're going to lose
representative ted liu of california
makes this particularly clear he said
yesterday that the 2022 midterms are
going to decide democracy well if you
actually believe this then why not
change all the rules if you change all
the rules then presumably you won't lose
as badly
democracy itself is on the ballot this
november
147 republicans voted to not certify the
electoral college results and more than
a year later not a single one of them
can identify who allegedly stole the
election nor explained how it was done
and that's because election was not
stolen donald trump got crushed in a
popular vote he lost electoral college
and what we see are republican
legislators trying to nullify the vote
instead of adhering to our democracy
okay so his idea is what if we
completely revise the rules for how this
stuff is done because if we don't do
that then so in order for them to we
have to stop them from stealing
elections by stealing elections is the
basic idea here
we have to burn the republic
the republican like small our republican
village in order to save the small d
democratic village if you want to save
democracy you have to end democracy you
have to kill the filibuster you have to
redo how all the voting is done by the
way it was five seconds ago the
democrats were defending the filibuster
here was chuck schumer just a few years
back talking about how eliminating the
filibuster would be doomsday for
democracy this is 2005.
the ideologues in the senate
want to turn what the founding fathers
called the cooling saucer of democracy
into the rubber stamp of dictatorship
we will not let them they want because
they can't get their way on every judge
to change the rules in midstream
to wash away 200 years of history they
want to make this country into a banana
republic where if you don't get your way
you change the rules are we gonna let
them
it'll be a doomsday for democracy if we
do i mean i wish that chuck schumer
today met this chuck schumer from the
past right it would be very interesting
to watch as they they stare at each
other confused because everything that
he's like chuck schumer is just a war
with his old self because again when it
comes to politics consistency is the
hobgoblin of little minds you're all for
killing the filibuster when it favors
you and you're all for keeping the
filibuster when it favors you and it's
death for democracy whenever you don't
get your way
okay that's really what this this
january 6 stuff is is about it it was by
the way within 24 hours of january 6
we'll get to that in one second first
let us talk about crypto so i am a fan
of crypto i own crypto i own some
bitcoin i own some ethereum i'm a fan of
crypto because i don't like the
centralized government determining how
much my assets are worth i'm just not a
fan of it with an alto crypto ira you
can trade crypto like bitcoin and you
can avoid or defer the taxes get into
investing in crypto do it in a tax
advantage retirement account alto's
crypto ira is the easy way to get crypto
into an ira trade all you want without
the tax headache create an account in
just a few minutes invest with as little
as 10 bucks no setup charges secure
trading at 247 through alto's
integration with coinbase there are 80
plus coins available including bitcoin
ethereum and cardano if you want some
sushi swap with your bitcoin no problem
alto has you covered they've got
industry-leading security advanced
encryption standard for wallets and
private keys as well if you're ready to
take your investments to the next level
you don't want to leave all of your
money in the hands of the federal
government diversify like the pros and
trade without tax headaches open an alto
crypto ira with as little as 10 bucks
just go to
dot com slash ben that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a dot com slash ben start
investing in cryptocurrency today go to
alto ira.com
ben all right so again the the basic
idea here is that january 6 is an excuse
for everything that we want to do ever
and forever right because republicans
are fonts of misinformation therefore we
have to have social media shutting them
down i mean representative for military
paul by the way she says that this
should become a thing that twitter and
facebook should just shut down anyone
who disagrees with her because again
threat to democracy right it's always
it's always some deep threat that
requires basic freedoms to be curbed
it's no secret that our social media
companies have been part of their
algorithms promoting disinformation and
i think that these steps are important
but frankly a little too little and a
little too late
the reality is it's not just marjorie
taylor green all over twitter social
media facebook
all of these companies have been using
algorithms that are just about clickbait
not about truth and so if we are
going to
take on the disinformation that's out
there the big lie and everything else
that goes with it then yes this is a
part of it but it's got to be much much
more we we have to crack down on the
first amendment in order to save the
first amendment we have to crack down on
your ability to to vote with a certain
amount of certainty in order to save
voting right
it's it's amazing how often they use
this logic
in fact we have to we have to curb all
of the traditional institutions of
american democracy in order to save
american democracy according to
professor jedediah britton purdy a
professor of constitutional law at
colombia
he has a piece in the new york times
called the republican party is
succeeding because we are not a true
democracy oh so when you win it's a
democracy and when you lose it's not a
true democracy i kind of see how this is
working
the january sixth attack would not have
happened in a genuine democracy
says uh britain purdy
really because i feel like uh the the
entire summer of 2020 before trump
and january 6. before any of that
happened
attacks on federal courthouses in
portland massive riots across the united
states like dozens if not hundreds of
riots across the united states uh like
it wouldn't have happened and it went so
you explained to me when exactly was
there a genuine democracy in the united
states and and no violence involved ever
i mean what was that period exactly
says professor britton purdy the attack
was the most acute symptom of the
political crisis that donald trump
incited by refusing to admit defeat in
the 2020 election but the roots of the
crisis run deep into the undemocratic
features of our constitutional system
at a basic level today's republican
party succeeds only because the
electoral college the senate and the
supreme court all tilt in its favor that
system has handed conservatives a 6-3
majority on the supreme court despite
the fact that only one republican has
won the presidential popular vote after
1988. a party doesn't have to persuade
majorities it has the best vision for
the country it only has to persuade a
selective minority that the other side
is a mortal threat its grasp on power
may be too tenuous for the party to
govern effectively but it has offered
conservatives a fine perch to weaken
economic and environmental regulation
appoint conservative judges and launch
attacks on the democratic system itself
in a more democratic system says this
professor of constitutional law the
republican party's extreme elements
would have been sent packing long before
they stormed the capitol because they
couldn't muster enough votes to win a
national election instead they have
perfected minority rule as a path to
political success an anti-democratic
system has bred an anti-democratic party
the remedy is to democratize our
so-called democracy yes pure
majoritarianism
what the founders called mob rule will
certainly make things much better
because when the mob rules nothing bad
ever happens when you have just a pure
majority cramming down its opinions on
the minority without without any sort of
of hampering mechanisms
then only good comes from that as we
know from none of world history ever
that this is the this is the basic idea
for the democrats if we just go to pure
majoritarianism then it'll be good by
the way if they start to lose in a pure
majoritarian state like let's say that
the next republican presidential
candidate in 2024 wins a popular vote
then we'll be back to well what what
systems are broken here that could have
allowed this to possibly happen
okay again january 6th is all about
exploitation it was never about january
6th purely
and that is the problem if it had been
just about january 6 we all would have
agreed if it's about the exploitation
then we all ought to not agree because
it is really really
kind of gross to use a a
horrible riot on january 6th
not nearly as horrible in terms of
property damage or loss of life is
anything that happened in 2020 by the
way
but a horrible image for the united
states to use that as an excuse to
batter away traditional institutions
like the filibuster as well as the state
control over voting rights
in order to shore up your chances in
2022 that seems like much more of a
threat to democracy than 200 droogs
invading the capitol building getting
themselves arrested and thrown in jail
alrighty in just one second we'll get
into the latest on america's covet
response which is just completely
chaotic and insane we'll get to that in
just one moment first
gas prices of course are ridiculously
high if you could save money on gas why
would you not do so right now which is
why i am thrilled to introduce an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now use promo code shapiro get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price of the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free use promo code shapiro
get up to 50 cents per gallon cashback
on your very first tank some people who
drive a lot are making as much as two or
three hundred bucks a month in cash back
there is no catch the cash back gets
added directly to your account
you can cash out anytime to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that is promo code shapiro get that free
get upside app today use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank of gas 25
that cents per gallon on your first fill
up although well actually beyond beyond
the 50 cents per gallon for philip 25
cents per gallon on every fill up after
that go check out that get upside app
today alrighty meanwhile
joe biden is trying to happy talk his
way through a bunch of horrible policy
decisions so he said yesterday that we
are entering 2022 in great economic
condition which is a shock to everybody
who's looking around going hold up
aren't half the companies in america
about to be hit with a vax mandate by
you and isn't the economy slowing and
aren't we experiencing stills supply
chain problems and inflation here's joe
biden trying to happy talk his way
through this one
before we begin i want to say a word
about where our economy stands today
we're entering 2022 in a position of a
unique economic strength
six million new jobs a record number for
a new president been created since
january last
unemployment is down to 4.2 percent
three years ahead of predictions
new small business applications are up
over 30 percent
compared with before the pandemic
and the fastest growth in america in
nearly 40 years
um so here is the thing nobody actually
believes that the economy is growing the
way that it should be growing right now
no one actually believed that which is
why that old dullard's approval ratings
are down in like the low 40s that is why
while he sits in a fake oval office with
a bunch of projected snow behind him
very exciting stuff from the president
of the united states by the way he does
have excuses for why all the failures
and the answer is it's everybody else's
fault i am i will say i am highly amused
by the new democratic line the companies
have only now discovered the possibility
of economic self-interest so the
entirety of free-market economics is
based on the idea that human beings are
self-interested in fact that is the
basis of much of classical liberal
thought generally whether you're a
conservative or a classical liberal the
basis of a lot of political thought over
the course of the last several centuries
has been the idea that human beings are
motivated by self-interest but
apparently all these companies only
discovered self-interest the moment that
inflation began to rise so it's not that
inflation is rising across the economy
because this guy poured money on a
raging fire of inflation already
it's not because of that it's because
meat companies suddenly got greedy
honestly if you believe this you deserve
a person like joe biden as your
president if you believe this you should
have a president whose neuron stopped
firing a couple of decades ago
here's joe biden trying to explain why
it is that meat prices are rising his
answer is that suddenly the beef
companies got greedy as opposed to you
know his bad economic policy
four big corporations control more than
half of the markets in beef
pork and poultry
these middlemen that they buy from
farmers and ranchers
and sell the processors they shoot me
and sell the process
excuse me sell the processed product to
grocery stores that's that's the way it
works
without meaningful competition farmers
and ranchers don't get to choose who
they sell to
or put another way
our farmers and ranchers have to pay
whatever these
four big companies say they have to pay
by and large
but that's only half of it
these companies can use their position
as middlemen to overcharge grocery
stores and ultimately families okay so
it's amazing so every so
every time there is a shortage it is not
the government that is to blame it is it
is the meat companies right it's the
meat companies so the until now the meat
companies were totally altruistic and
they were fine and they were never
greedy or self-interested and then
suddenly as inflation began to rise it
was all the meat companies he uses
exactly the same language that bernie
sanders uses about the banks everybody
just gets greedy randomly as soon as
democrats need an excuse for why their
policies are failing it's the evil evil
meat companies of course it's the evil
meat companies it's not your centralized
government top-down approach to how
distribution ought to be done and how
taxation and redistribution ought to be
pursued it's pretty incredible stuff
it's no wonder that america is currently
suffering from all sorts of economic
uncertainty despite the fact that we
should be booming at this point in
unprecedented fashion
meanwhile major companies around the
united states are implementing joe
biden's covet 19 of vaccine mandates
okay those companies are are likely to
get slammed with labor shortages because
if you actually fire all your workers
who won't get the facts because they
have natural immunity many of them then
you're going to end up with labor
shortage right now there's a lot of talk
about hospital shortages hey the reality
is that the hospitals are not inundated
with cases like hospitalized cases with
kovid in the same way they were during
the delta surge that's because delta is
much more serious than omicron but there
are shortages anyway one of the reasons
that there are shortages is because as
has been widely reported many hospitals
have been laying people off who are not
vast
and the same thing is about to happen
across the economy
according to the wall street journal
starbucks is now requiring u.s employees
to be vaccinated against coven 19 or
submit to regular testing one of the
first large restaurant chains to take
such a step ahead of potential federal
vax mandates for large employers
starbucks said on monday workers in its
u.s cafes offices and manufacturing
plans must be vaccinated by february 9th
or get tested weekly workers who choose
testing must have a pharmacist or doctor
administer it instead of taking one at
home workers will need to to themselves
obtain and cover any cost for the test
the company said in a message to u.s
stores so the company's not going to
cover the task you're going to cover the
cost of the test so given the fact that
tests are in extraordinarily low supply
right now it could cost you hundreds but
like more than you're making at
starbucks in order to test yourself to
work at starbucks which means
unemployment u.s workers must disclose
their vaccination status by january 10th
according to starbucks
starbucks ceo john culver wrote in a
message to employees last week he
understands workers have a range of
views on vaccination but he said
starbucks is strongly encouraging all
workers to get vaccinated particularly
as the omicron variant spreads
last month the federal appellate court
reinstated the abide administration
rules that require businesses with 100
or more employees to ensure their
workers are vaccinated or tested weekly
for covet-19 the supreme court is going
to hear oral arguments early this month
possibly late this week
on this particular and we have already
submitted
amicus briefs and we are the first major
american company to sue the biden
administration in the sixth circuit
court of appeals we urge you to head on
over to our petition over at
dailywire.com
do not comply please sign our petition
against the biden vax mandate we have
over a million signatures on that
well as companies start to do this it's
just going to exacerbate a labor
shortage that is already driving up
wages which is driving up prices which
is driving up inflation
and here is the thing
all of these bax mandates were
originally designed not just to protect
you against the virus they were designed
to protect you from infecting your
neighbors but as we all know pretty much
everybody you know is getting a
breakthrough case of omicron right now
and so the spread is not being prevented
by the vaccines
it may be mitigated to a certain extent
although we have no statistical idea
what the differential is between the vax
to getting omicron and the unvacs
getting omicron what we do know is that
the vax are
are
responding in better fashion to omicron
than the unboxed although omicron
generally is less dangerous than delta
however if the basic idea of the vast
mandate is we have to create a safe a
safe workplace where you're not going to
get coveted which is the idea behind the
osha vax mandate well the vax doesn't
prevent you from getting coveted it
prevents you from dying from coven being
hospitalized i'm a big vac fan
but that's not the idea here the idea is
that osha can prevent externalities
right there's no vax mandate that osha
could cram down that only protects you
against death so for example
if you
let's say that there were a vax that
prevented you from dying of the flu but
did not prevent transmission of the flu
osha would have really no business
cramming down a vax mandate on that
basis because again it's about the
externalities it's about creating a
quote-unquote safe workplace
okay so if you're still passing it and
you're vaccinated
that sort of defeats the purpose of the
vax mandate does it not at least when it
comes to transmission which is what osha
is involved in
so all this is going to lead to pretty
massive
economic standstills
bunch of economic hiccups by the way in
canada they're already shutting down
everything again i mean it's crazy over
there in canada
my friend jordan peterson has been
tweeting about it apparently ontario is
now in full lockdown restrictions
include delaying in-person learning at
schools shutting down gyms indoor dining
reducing capacity for retail to 50
percent
and by the way i'm just wondering at
this point why exactly are we doing this
like
where is the evidence that we are seeing
a massive increase in covet death
new york state right now his experience
in new york state
on average is experiencing a seven day
rolling average of 91 deaths per day
from covid
that is up very very slightly from a
month ago
despite the fact that the case has
absolutely skyrocketed the same thing is
true in pretty much every state if you
look at washington dc washington dc's
covet death rate okay they're running
deaths in washington dc
one that is the seven day rolling
average of death you know what it was
like several months ago one
okay despite the fact that the case rate
is extraordinary in washington dc
so they're they're continuing to
promote this these lock down policies in
places like washington dc and joe biden
is promoting all that and then we're
supposed to
wonder why exactly the economy is
stalling out
by the way meanwhile joe biden has been
involving himself in seizing all of the
monoclonal antibodies
he's federalizing all monoclonal
antibody distribution so that he can
pass them out to his friends
that of course is pretty bad policy but
but not a particular shock it's also
true by the way that that now omicron is
spreading
throughout congress congress is heavily
vaccinated
at this point
the number of new yorkers who have been
hospitalized with coronavirus infections
topped about 9 500 on monday that
surpassed the peak reached during last
year's winter wave but that's the number
of new yorkers who have hospitalized
with coronavirus not necessarily from
coronavirus as by the way anthony falci
says because a lot of people are going
to hospitals and then they're being
diagnosed with covet while they are in
the hospital already
the the basic idea that hospitalizations
and that hospitalizations with covid and
from colvin are exactly the same thing
is patently untrue given the fact that
you are now being asymptomatically
tested for covid
beyond that
the fda is now authorizing covet vaccine
boosters for 12 to 15 year olds there's
no evidence that 12 to 15 year olds need
vaccine boosters
i mean again the total number of kids
who have died from covid to this point
in the pandemic people under the age of
18 is still under 700.
more kids die of drowning in a given
year than have died of covid over the
course of two years
and now they are authorizing boosters
for 12 to 15 year olds
like everyone let's let's say everyone
is getting omicron every single human
but they got vast where they didn't get
facts again you should get facts and the
reason you should get vast is because
then you won't be hospitalized or die
from covet
right omicron is not nearly as dangerous
as delta but theoretically you could
still die from it you're much more
likely to die from it if you're unvaxed
i've been talking with hospital
administrators around the country what
they say is that the hospitalizations
that they are seeing are generally among
the unvaxxed with omicron
but that does not mean that everybody
isn't going to get coveted everyone's
going to get covered at this point
for example yesterday the view announced
that whoopi goldberg had coveted they
had to do the entire show remote would
be his triple vaxxed i believe
as you can see we're back in boxes and
doing the show remotely hopefully
for just a week i'm praying that it's
just a week but you never know because
this omicron thing is
all over the place all over the place
um why am i here instead of whoopi well
whoopi unfortunately tested positive
over the break but she'll be back
probably next week um but since she's
waxed and boosted her symptoms have been
very very mild but we're you know being
super cautious here at the view uh we'll
be checking with her uh soon so you'll
see we'll be too by the way the lockdown
fanatics are not stopping anytime in
here randy weingarten the worst
actor in american public life she came
out yesterday and she says that she
wants students five plus to be forced to
vax in order for them to go back to
school
in terms of vaccines i think what gavin
newsom did in california is really the
best model which is that the semester
after
they are they go from emergency use to
full authorization and the fda has done
everything that they need to do
that's what california has said that is
the semester that they become mandatory
but and you support that nationally and
i and and i i personally support that
the union hasn't taken a position on
that okay but the union will take a
position on that because teachers had a
great year okay let's be
the great heroes of our society there
are some teachers who really wanted to
teach okay this is not about the
teachers the teachers unions the great
heroes of our society they spent the
last year being able to teach from home
telling people to print out stuff on
their non-existent printers a lot of
people don't necessarily have printers
teaching on zoom kids lost a full year
of school and the teachers still got
paid teachers still got so they're happy
to continue this as long as possible
michael osterholm who's an advisor to
the button administration he's saying
school should shut down again
right now we're seeing school districts
all across the united states that are
seeing hundreds and hundreds of teachers
out sick
bus drivers support staff how can you
have a school run when you have this
viral blizzard shutting down many many
of those in your educational system so
we're going to have to be flexible for
the next three to five weeks as we work
through this omicron crisis and realize
that we may not be able to open schools
not because we don't want to we want to
but you can't do it when you don't have
people no you don't want to you don't
want to because you know why you don't
have people because you're testing the
asymptomatic
that is one reason also because you're
not allowing people to go back to school
after just five days you want people to
test it
because you continue to maintain this
pandemic is going to end society when it
is not you could just be realistic
no by the way the left does not want to
be realistic okay because here's the
thing
even some of the hawks are starting to
be very become very realistic about this
right scott gottlieb former commissioner
of the fda he says we'll be done with
this in a month this is correct
i think certainly the february time
frame is appropriate in terms of when
we're going to pass through this omicron
wave
across the united states now this is a
big country this will affect different
parts of the country at different points
in time but if the uk is any guide
london's already peaking if south africa
is any guide this is about a two-month
epidemic wave from start to finish and
so parts of the country that were
affected earlier like new york probably
are going to start to peak in the next
two weeks other parts within the next
four weeks so i think certainly by the
end of february we will be through this
but no it's panic panic panic panic
we'll get to that in just one moment
first let's talk about the fact you
don't want to go to the auto parts store
because why would you ever want to go to
the auto parts store you stand in line
you finally get to the front of the line
you ask what part do i need for my car
and then he he asks you a bunch of
questions you don't know the answer to
finally he said he checks in the back
they don't have the part we can order
and we can up charge you 40
or you could just do this on the
interwebs like everything else you do
you have computers they have access to
rockauto.com why don't you just go check
it out why would you choose to spend 30
50 100 more for the exact same auto
parts at a chain store or a new car
dealership rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they've got
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's your
classic or daily driver get everything
you need and a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door the rockauto.com
catalog it's unique it's remarkably easy
to navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brand's specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com they're always reliably low
they're the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers why spend up to twice
as much for the same parts you've got
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com right shapiro in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you alrighty in just one
second we'll get to the complete lack of
realism among the lockdown fanatics
first i'm so excited about this so you
have new year's resolutions one of those
is you're going to read more this year
right well i'm going to help you because
i want to read with you we have a brand
new book club okay our brand new book
club every month we're going to go
through a classic and i'm going to be
talking with you about it once a month
i'm gonna recommend a book that has
cultural significance not just kind of
the the fancy pants new books with the
woke values or political books but like
actual classic literature this is great
for adults high school students college
students become the best version of
yourself by reading the books that
should be on your list maybe the stuff
that you never read back in high school
read it along with me when you join the
book club you'll get access to my
personal notes and analysis of the books
and then on the third thursday of each
month i will join dailywire members
online for an in-depth lecture and
discussion of each book don't let this
year go by without investing time in
yourself go to third
thursdaybookclub.com that is t-h-i-r-d
third thursdaybookclub.com
we'll send you this month's book
recommendation some of the materials you
will need to participate in the members
only discussion on thursday january 20th
that is third thursday bookclub.com i'm
super pumped about this like i've been
pushing this behind the scenes for a
couple of years and i can't wait to hang
out with you guys and talk books it's my
favorite thing to do third
thursdaybookclub.com to join me also as
you know the daily wire led the charge
to sue the biden administration over the
vax mandates now we've taken it all the
way to the supreme court this friday the
supreme court is going to convene to
hear arguments on the legality and
constitutionality of the mandate that
means that this week is a big week in
our fight against medical tyranny
we have over a million signatures on our
do not comply petition currently you
need to help us okay before friday help
send the message loud and clear head on
over to dailywire.com do not comply
right now we're counting on you to help
us stop the vax mandate you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all right so the lockdown fanatics they
continue to to fail to recognize reality
so max boot who's just completely lost
his mind over trump right he used to be
like some of his books he had a book on
guerrilla warfare that's actually quite
good some of his military histories are
really interesting but max boot
unfortunately has has lost his
ever-loving mind he has a piece today in
the washington post targeting yours
truly titled omicron doesn't vindicate
right-wingers who refuse to take the
coronavirus seriously so first of all
let me just start here who didn't take
the coronavirus seriously like who
i i am one of the foremost proponents of
vaccination on the american right i have
been since literally the day the
vaccines were available and long before
even at the beginning of the pandemic i
suggested actually even all the way
until vaccines were available that
masking up around people who were
vulnerable was not a bad idea and that
if you were vulnerable you should be
masking up so i was not even anti-mask
until the vaccines were available then
the vaccines were available and then i
said we were done
okay well that happens to be following
the data according to max boot this
makes me anti some sort of anti-vaxx
person who refused to take kovid
seriously because of course taking kovid
seriously according to the left means
doing everything they say you should do
when they say you should do it that's
what it means to take over seriously so
here is max boot today when it comes to
dealing with kova 19 as with most things
i've been pretty cautious i downed i
dined outdoors last winter shivering in
the cold because indoor dining was too
dangerous i held off going to theaters
and concerts for a year i got my
vaccination shots three of them so far
as soon as they were available i always
wear a mask when in stores so why did i
risk a family trip to france over the
holidays despite record numbers of
coveted cases in both france and the
united states because this isn't 2020
anymore while omicron is more ubiquitous
than previous versions of the
coronavirus it appears to be less severe
it penetrates the upper airways but not
the lungs
moreover booster shots provide strong
protection against infection and even
better protection against
hospitalization
okay that's fine i i agree
but here is where he goes wrong so he
says
public health recommendations change as
the nature of the threat changes well
this is not right okay the public health
apparatus has not changed its
recommendations as the threat changed
they've been bouncing around like a ping
pong pole depending on what the bite
administration wants of them sometimes
it's locked down sometimes it's masking
sometimes it is no masking sometimes the
schools should be open sometimes they
should not be open sometimes we should
be deeply fearful of omicron and we
should count cases sometimes we should
stop counting the cases it all depends
on what is politically convenient
and at no point was there a suggestion
by the public health establishment that
maybe you should treat the virus
differently based on your age or prior
health condition or that maybe you
should just be left alone to make your
own decisions
because that's all the government could
do so anyway here's max boot again he's
going to blame me for the pandemic which
is which is good times he says
host ben shapiro posted a lengthy
twitter thread claiming that once it
became clear that coveted was not in
fact a pagan god visiting vengeance on
the unwashed trump voters alone the
media and democrats are now willing to
admit the following and went on to list
various assertions such as the death
rate is comparable to the flu and we
have to take into account societal needs
not just spread prevention and we should
not shut down society
she apparently shapiro triumphantly
concluded that omicron had vindicated
those of us who quote have been saying
all this for months and most of it since
may 2020. we chose data and freedom you
chose alarmism and unearned moral
superiority now the reason that i said
in the tweet thread that many of us have
been saying this for months and most of
it since may 2020 is because not all of
it applied in may 2020 right
it did not have the death rate of the
flu in may 2020. it does have the death
rate of the flu once you are vaccinated
and omicron seems to have about the
death rate of the flu generally right
somewhere in that neighborhood
but says max boot this is nonsense on
stilts it would be more accurate to say
that shapiro and company chose populist
ideology while the rest of us chose
science it takes only minimal scientific
literacy after all to realize that two
very different versions of the same
disease call for two very different
responses okay so he's just building a
straw man here and then burning it
he says one of the main reasons that
people haven't gotten vaccinated in worn
mask regularly is so many people are
listening to right-wing agitators like
ben shapiro who champion a misguided
idea of medical freedom shapiro's media
company the daily wire even sued to stop
president biden's well-warranted
vaccination mandate for companies with
more than a hundred employees
okay so in other words i'm bad because
even though i recommended vaccinations
have said that everyone who's an adult
in my family has been backs multiple
times my wife's been boosted my parents
have been boosted i've been vast
that doesn't matter according to max
boot because after all i'm not embracing
the craziest version of his reality by
the way what does he actually recommend
max boot
he says
our original alarm was not unwarranted
we need more masks and vaccine mandates
including a vaccination requirement for
domestic air travel
okay so he says he's pro data no you're
not you're not pro show me
show me the necessity for vaccination
requirements for domestic air travel one
iota of data this is either necessary or
that it will be effective
show me that it will be effective in
preventing spread and transmission
show me
show me also why you get to decide for
somebody else whether they need to get
vaccinated when this thing is still
widely transmissible and you are not
preventing the transmission by by
getting you're not obliviating
transmission by getting the facts
explain
the bottom line is some people are
wedded to the panic and they will never
stop the panic because the panic makes
them feel moral and better about
themselves
now in reality there are those of us who
continue to live in freedom
so to my home state of florida ron
desantis continues to be a 2024 leading
contender because the left cannot stop
itself they just cannot stop themselves
after joe biden
fled washington dc to delaware after
announcing that it was up to the states
to handle covet after spending his
entire presidential campaign saying he
would shut down copenhagen he was like
piss out guys and then he just sort of
wobbled out to delaware where he walked
down the beach alone wearing a mask
well he did that and then the media
didn't ask where is joe biden going and
why isn't he handling this instead
they're like where is ron desantis well
turns out that ron desantis was caring
for his wife
that he was dealing with the fact that
his wife had cancer and he was
accompanying her to treatments this
makes ronda sansa super bad here's ron
desantis yesterday pointing out uh yeah
i was going to my wife's cancer
treatment joe biden was on a beach why
wasn't anybody asking where he was
i think they're like oh my god he's on
vacation and i'm like you know and i
just looked at my wife i'm like you know
going to the hospital uh with you uh is
not a vacation for you i know that and
it's not a vacay i mean this is
something that as a husband i think that
i i should be doing i've accompanied her
to all her chemotherapy treatments and
she's there for a long time i mean you
know i'm there most of the time but it's
uh it's a draining thing when she's done
with it you know it's it's not it's it's
not something that that's great to see
and so i just think a lot of people
particularly people that have gone
through breast cancer treatments the
notion that that would be considered a
vacation i think is offensive to a lot
of those folks okay so the media decided
to target rhonda sanchez because they
didn't want to target joe biden of
course and then ron desantis is the
governor of florida my home state the
best governor of america
he says you know i've noticed that a lot
of you and your lockdown friends are
coming down to florida to vacation
because you're a bunch of hypocritical
ridiculous people uh here he is talking
about that
well i mean look i i think if if you if
i had a dollar
for every lockdown politician
who decided to escape to florida over
the last two years i'd be a pretty
doggone wealthy man let me tell you i
mean congress people mayors governors i
mean you name it and uh it's interesting
though the reception that you know that
some of these folks will get in florida
because i think a lot of floridians say
wait a minute you're bashing us because
we're not doing your draconian policies
and yet we're the first place you want
to flee to
to basically to be able to to to enjoy
life and so i'm not surprised to see
that continue to happen
by the way ron desantis again the chief
of the non-panic coalition right the why
don't we deal with this with with
treatment that that saves lives and is
useful
that guy who's been pilloried by the
media well andrew cuomo was upheld by
the media who he was killing all the
olds when not grabbing ass in new york
and ron desantis
again he points out that it's joe biden
who's now attempting to centralize all
of the monoclonal antibodies it was
rhonda santos who was talking about
monoclonals months ago when the entire
mainstream media was saying that he was
a fool for doing so
we have the ability and we will
immediately turn on additional sites as
soon as the federal government gives us
a supply we will do an additional site
here in broward county we'll do an
additional site in miami-dade we'll do
an additional site in palm beach county
we'll do an additional site in central
florida and we also have the capacity to
increase of the existing footprint which
we do have a good existing footprint and
we have the ability to add
five to 10 more sites as the demand uh
may be but that is all contingent
on the federal government sending uh the
doses uh that we need okay well the
federal government joe biden probably
won't allow that because if joe biden
would allow people to have the
monoclonals then then they might
actually get treated and then we
couldn't have a crisis anymore okay so i
want to make one final cultural note
that i'd be remiss if i didn't point out
okay this story is just it
it is so demonstrative of everything
that the left has become
it truly is an amazing thing so patton
oswalt is a wild leftist crazy person he
is a stand-up comic who is most famous
for voicing the rat in ratatouille
and uh and he is he's still doing some
stand-up kind of stuff again everything
that he does is wildly to the left pat
and oswald so
on new year's eve he was doing a comedy
club and in the comedy club next door
was dave chappelle
and so he took a picture with dave
chappelle and he put up a post on
instagram and said finished my set at
mccall and got a text from dave
chappelle come over to the arena he's
performing in next door into a guest set
why not i waved goodbye to this hell
year with a genius i started comedy with
34 years ago he works in arena like he's
talking one person and charming their
skin off anyway i ended the year with a
real friend and a deep laugh can't ask
for much more oh it's a nice way to end
the year isn't that nice there's only
one problem of course patton oswald is
of the left and dave chappelle has
offended the alphabet people as he likes
to say he's offended the trans activists
who have suggested that he's a very very
bad evil bad man for noting that men and
women exist
so patton oswalt then had to reverse
himself because cowards don't get killed
they get their friends killed cowards
are the people who ensure that their
friends are the ones thrown under them
in fact they help with throwing under
the bus i hope that dave chappelle goes
to war with pat and oswald i desperately
hope it because pat oswalt deserves it
so he he put up a picture
that i just have to describe for you for
a moment it is a picture of patton
oswalt
sitting in front of a yellow legal pad
his headphones plugged into his
his phone
staring at himself in the mirror
or at least looking down and then the
pictures of him in a mirror because he's
he's really you know he's he's doing
some introspection
so the glor
the utter narcissism a picture of him
with another image of him in the mirror
both of whom are staring down at the
pence at the pad of paper where they are
writing their forced apology maoist
maoist struggle session note quote
i saw a friend i hadn't seen in a long
time this new year's eve we've known
each other since we're teens he's a
fellow comedian the funniest i've ever
met i wanted to post a pic and an
instagram story about it so i did the
friend is dave chappelle 34 years we've
been friends he's refocused and refined
ideas a lot of us took and settled about
race and history and life on planet
earth and spun them around with a phrase
or a punchline we've done bad and good
gigs open mics and tv tapings but we
also 100 disagree about transgender
rights and representation i support
trans people's rights anyone's rights to
live safely in the world as their
fullest selves for all the things he's
helped me evolve on i'll always disagree
with where he stands now on transgender
issues but i also don't believe a secret
like him is done evolving learning you
know someone that long see the struggles
and changes it's impossible to cut them
off impossible not to be hopeful and
open and cheer them on also i've been
carrying a lot of guilt about friends
i've cut off who had views with which i
couldn't agree or changed in ways i
couldn't live with sometimes i wonder
did i and others cutting them off make
them dig their heels in deeper fuel
their ignorance with a nitro boost of
resentment in spite
i'm in lgbtq plus ia open bracket closed
bracket tilde
little
little equals sign
ally i'm a loyal friend there's a
friction in those traits that i need to
reconcile myself and not let cause feels
of betrayal in anyone else
and i'm sorry truly sorry that i didn't
consider the hurt this would cause or
the depth of that hurt i've been
messaging a lot on ig today and the back
and forth has really helped guide me in
the writing of this i naively deleted a
lot of posts in the comment thread
critical ones from lgbtq writers and
bleep posts by turf anti-trans orcs
looking for clicks and giggles i wanted
a nice comment thread about the pick
with my friend ugh so easy to think
someone else needs growth and miss the
need in yourself gonna keep trying
oh isn't that nice but he's not really
talking about the growth of himself most
of that post is about how dave chappelle
needs to grow and change and the only
reason he's staying friends with dave
chappelle is because he hopes that dave
chappelle will one day come to embrace
his own views so this is not him saying
i can embrace a friend who disagrees
with me on this issue this isn't saying
the only reason i embrace this friend is
because one day he will embrace my views
on this issue which by the way is the
opposite of friendship
okay if the idea is that you can only be
friends with people who agree with you
on everything
or people who you believe that you will
eventually convince to agree with you on
everything that does not seem like
somebody that should be friends with you
because what if 10 years from now they
look around and dave chappelle still
feels the same way that he does today
because by the way dave chappelle is
correct
is patton oswald then gonna cut him off
right now his excuse is i still think i
can make a difference with you i can
save tay i can make dave lgbtq plus ia
open carrot
british pound sign ampersand ally and
because of that i'm still gonna be
friends with dave but if he can't well
then isn't he obligated to throw dave
under the bus
and isn't that really what he's doing
right now he's saying that the reason
that he's friends with dave is because
he's superior to dave
this is so much of the virtue signaling
right it is it is all about for people
like patton oswalt it is all about
signaling to everyone that they are
better than you he's so introspective
he's so thoughtful he's so he's so
wonderful right he's he's right on the
issues and he's broad-minded enough to
know that his stupid friend doesn't
believe what he believes and that one
day his stupid friend may come to
believe what he believes and that's why
he's sorry that he took a picture with
that friend and didn't note in there
that his friend also is a bigot a
vicious wild bigot but he should still
be friends with him
man i hope that dave chappelle just
wrecks him because no one deserves it
more than the rat man patton oswalt my
goodness all right we will be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out our
newest podcast morning wire today's
episode they discuss u.s population
growth reaching record lows also the
reasons behind joe rogan joining the new
social media site getter that episode is
available right now on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts make
sure to tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wiedowsky associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high events audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
kranz the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire
[Music]